-You did a good job.
Fran. Franny.
Are you ready
for the show tonight?
We have a big show tonight.
Do you know who's
on the show tonight?
-Who?
-Captain America.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Captain America
is on the show tonight.
Chris Evans
Also, we have Kane Brown.
Good music from Kane Brown.
-Yeah.
-You like him. He's good.
But guess who else
is on the show.
-Yeah.
-Hmm, who writes
"Elephant and Piggie" books?
-Mo Willems!
-That's right!
Mo Willems is on the show!
-Whoo!
"Don't Let the Pigeon
Drive the Bus!"
-Ohh. [ Babbling ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Do you know
"City Dog, Country Frog"?
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
-...Mo Willems.
-Mo Willems is on the show
tonight, and he's going to
draw with Daddy.
Isn't that fun?
-Mm-hmm.
-What are you guys eating?
Where'd you find Tic Tacs?
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Way old. Are they soft?
-♪ We in the house ♪
♪ Come on ♪
-Tonight,
join Jimmy and his guests.
Chris Evans...
Mo Willems...
musical guest Kane Brown...
and the legendary Roots Crew.
It's "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
-♪ We in the house, y'all ♪
-And now here's Jimmy.
-All right. Let's get
to some jokes here. Ready?
Today more experts
testified before Congress
about the coronavirus,
but who wants to
follow Dr. Fauci?
That's like hearing,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
that, of course,
was the Beatles reunited.
Now give it up
for the modern-dance trickery
of the Jabbawockeez.
-Huh?
-What are you doing?
-I'm dancing.
That's right. Today
vaccine expert Dr. Rick Bright
said that without
better planning,
2020 could be the darkest winter
in modern history.
Yeah, it's not a good sign
when our experts sound
like the Night's Watch
on "Game of Thrones."
"Winter is coming."
Can we see a photo
of Dr. Bright testifying today?
Ouch. That's not a face mask.
That's a man's head
in a slingshot.
Hey, I saw that Disney Plus
is coming out
with a six-episode series
about the making of "Frozen 2."
-They already did.
-No, no. They're coming out
with a six-episode series
about the making of "Frozen 2."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause there's nothing
kids love more
than destroying the magic
of an animated film.
Get this. A Broadway show based
on the life of Michael Jackson
has been postponed
until next March...
when it will still
not be a good idea.
-Um, I saw that
as restaurants reopen,
many will only offer
disposable menus.
That's too bad. My favorite part
of the meal was opening the menu
and seeing all the stains from
the people who ate before me.
[ Chuckles ]
[Southern accent] "We definitely
gotta order that gravy, honey.
We gotta order that gravy, huh?
Yeah, that looks good!
Drippin' on that menu
like that."
What? You like that?
[ Laughs ]
You don't like that voice?
[ Normal voice ]
All right. Listen to this.
Krispy Kreme announced that
they're running a special offer
of 12 free doughnuts
to graduating
high-school seniors.
That's nice.
So even if colleges don't open,
you'll still get a jump
on the freshman fifteen.
Maybe they'll come home
and unplug your treadmill
and your workout equipment,
as well.
This is getting crazy.
There are reports
that Kim Jong-un
is once again missing.
When they heard that,
North Korean officials
were like, "Okay..."
[ Rattling ]
-♪ No Tic Tac, no Tic Tac, no ♪
-♪ Tic Tac, Tic Tac ♪
-Mommy.
Mommy.
-That's not a song, right?
-♪ Tic Tac, Tic Tac ♪
-No, that's not.
That's not a song.
-It is now.
-All right, guys.
Almost done here.
Here we go. Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Giggling ]
-There are reports
that Kim Jong-un
is once again missing.
When they heard that, North
Korean officials were like,
"Okay, we need to get one of
those Bluetooth key finders
and glue it to his back."
"All right. Get him getting
close and shark-tag his ass."
[ Girls giggling ]
Hey! Sit down, guys.
In the back.
Be careful. We're not driving.
And finally, scientists
just determined
how fast the virus can travel
in a restaurant
using a blacklight.
Scientists said
they learned two things.
The virus travels quickly...
and never turn on a black light
at a Denny's.
There you guys have it.
That's my monologue right there.
We have a great show,
as I said. Chr--
[ Girls giggling ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Are you okay?
-Chris Evans is here.
You guys, we have Mo Willems,
great author.
We're going to draw
with Mo Willems later
and talk to him.
And then we have music
from Kane Brown. It's great.
But first,
how about a little Hashtags?
Do you want to do
some Hashtags?
♪♪
-♪ Hashtags ♪
-Okay. Here we go. We're going
to do some hashtags. Okay?
This is a part of the show
where we play along on the Web.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to play Hashtags.
This is where we give a topic
on the Web, right?
And then you could tweet.
Can you not see me again?
You can't see me, right?
But you can see everybody else.
Where's Mommy?
Where's Harry?
Where's Winnie? Where's Daddy?
Yeah.
[ Girls giggling ]
I don't understand this game.
Can you see Daddy?
-Do it again.
-I'm right here. Where's Mommy?
We can't even see Mommy, either?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Girls speaking indistinctly ]
-This is...
This is all..
-Ah! Yeah!
-No, no. We're all
in the back of the bus.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Doing some Hashtags.
Ready for this first one?
-Mm-hmm.
-This first one's from
@Kerry08270639.
She said, "I'm going to dress up
as Mel Gibson in 'Braveheart'
and scream FREEDOM
as I enter every bar I find."
[ Laughs ]
You should do that.
Okay, let's just
stay seated here.
This one's from...
She said, "Channel a Walmart
greeter to everyone I meet.
'Hi. Hello. Welcome.
Yay! You're here!
So nice to see you."
It's like -- Yes, everyone
be in a great mood like that.
-Yeah!
-This one's from...
She said,
"Go down the toilet-paper aisle
like Julia Andrews
in 'The Sound of Music.'"
♪ The hills are alive ♪
-[ Mimicking Jimmy ]
-♪ With the sound of Charmin ♪
-This one's from...
She said, "I'm going to
buy tickets to Hawaii
for my whole family and
drop them off at the airport."
[ Imitates explosion ]
Dunked on that one.
[ Laughs ]
That was a good one.
-That one didn't make sense.
-This one is from...
She said, "Stop picking my
outfits from the waist up only."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from...
She said, "Load my kids up
on the Easter candy
that I've been hiding,
drop them off at my parents and
then yell, 'Tag. You're it.'"
[ Laughs ]
-Are you giving me
an off the shoulder?
Ooh. Thank you.
-[ Giggles ]
-This is from --
This one's from...
[ Laughter ]
"I'm going to enter
real meetings
like they're a Zoom meeting."
"Hey, can everyone hear me?
Hello? Can you guys hear me?
Am I unmuting?
So I mute myself?"
This one's from...
She said, "Finally
see my husband again.
We've been quarantined together,
but whatever this personality
is is not what I signed up for."
[ Laughter ]
That's a funny one.
-This one is from --
Last one's from...
He said, "Whenever I check out
at the grocery store,
I'm gonna buy
one six-pack for me
and one six-pack
for the cashier."
Yeah, baby! I love that!
That's our Hashtags right there.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪